he looked fresh and Breezy and very
pleased to be there
International Pariah Basha al-assad
ready to return to the stage
the Syrian president is regarded as a
war criminal by much of the world a
label his hosts Saudi Arabia applied
until recently
but at the airport in Jeddah before the
Arab League Summit he was offered
handshakes and smiles and sweet words of
Welcome Assad's role in the destruction
of his own country in the deaths of half
a million or more didn't come up during
the family photos it seems members of
the Arab League have decided to forgive
and forget despite the fact that many
here tried to unseat him
that was something the Syrian president
brought up Rather pointedly with this
he said we need to heal the cracks that
emerged on the Arab scene the league
should restore its role in healing
wounds not deepening them and leave
Internal Affairs to its own people
the charge sheet is voluminous Assad led
a regime that murdered its opponents and
leveled its cities
his re-emergence on the international
stage an unfortunate recognition of
reality I think it shows that Assad has
successfully survived and survived his
leader through 12 years of internal
conflict in Syria so certainly there is
an acceptance by the region that he is
there to stay and that is the reason
that he is being rehabilitated the guest
list at this year's Summit included
another leader looking to make new
friends the Ukrainian president the
Vladimir zelensky
typically on his International visits he
asks for weapons and aid but in a Punchy
address he told the Arab League the time
had come to pick a side unfortunately
there are some in the world and here
among you who tore a blind eye to those
cages and illegal annexations and I am
here so that everyone can take an honest
look no matter how hard the Russians try
to influence
more bonomy in Jeddah as Basha Allah
said sinks into a comfy chair with the
leader of Tunisia it's almost like the
last 12 years never happened
and that's exactly what the Syrian
president wants
John Sparks Sky News